- [Narrator] Music plays an
important role in our lives.
It can help is relax, concentrate,
or get pumped for a work out.
And if this song makes you happy,
well, it's because it's
affecting your brain chemistry.
So why do we find music so enjoyable?
Researchers from McGill
University in Montreal
found that dopamine
releases during moments
of enjoyment while listening to music.
It's what gives us the chills.
The same chemical reaction
as when you fall in love.
Basically, listening to music is amazing
and your brain loves it.
Music also distracts your
brain from registering
the body's fatigue.
It increases endurance while improving
the heart and muscles,
giving music both a
psychological and physiological
impact on the body.
Think about that next
time you're at the gym
and forget your headphones.
And did you know that
playing a musical instrument
can make you smarter?
And more of an annoying neighbor.
Sorry Charlie.
Believe it or not, children
with at least three
years of musical training performed better
during testing for nonverbal reasoning,
fine motor skills,
auditory discrimination,
and vocabulary than those who did not.
We generally don't
realize how a simple song
can affect our brains and bodies.
Nevertheless, music has
a measurably significant
effect on human beings,
influencing the way we dance,
exercise, and think.
So how has music affected your life?
(upbeat music)